when I think of Superman I think of Ben
Affleck to be honest with you but to be
fair
most movie characters I feel could be
played by Ben Affleck including the
shark and Jaws so take it with a grain
of salt hey GQ Kevin Smith back to talk
about even more comic book movies and
the characters that I love let's Dive In
[Music]
how you nail that role in my estimation
is how you play Clark Kent because Clark
Kent is the mask Superman's the guy the
actual person he dresses up like Clark
Kent to hide who he is playing Superman
is difficult enough right because
essentially you're playing Pop Culture
Jesus which is difficult because Jesus
is pop culture Jesus but like Superman's
like kind of right up there one of the
most recognizable figures on the planet
no matter what language you speak and
you know I was raised Catholic and I was
an altar boy and I did eight years of
Catholic school but most of my morality
came from Reading comic books
[Music]
uh good evening officer Mooney
well they say confession is good for the
soul
[Music]
I'd listen to this man
take them away you know Batman my
favorite comical character of all time
but Batman pretty selfish right he's
like my parents are dead and the World's
Gonna Pay by never having that happen to
anybody else but I'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of muggers and chain snatchers for
the rest of my life
[Applause]
sweet and appeals to like you know any
sort of like yeah go get them Batman
nature that's in you but Superman isn't
about that Superman would try to save
somebody try to turn them from Evil try
anything rather than just beat them up
the only people he beats up tend to be
Larger than Life figures with super
strength come from other planets and
stuff all the actors who have saved the
role of Superman in the movies I'm very
partial to Chris Reeve I grew up with
Chris Reeve Superman I was familiar with
George Reeve Superman from Black and
White shows and reruns when I was a kid
but this is going to be ironic coming
from the guy who made clerks I didn't
like black and white when I was a kid
Chris Reeves Superman was my childhood
an amazing actor who carried both
characters insanely well and that
incarnation of Superman will forever be
the closest to the source material as
possible because he stands for oh Chris
Reeve created a completely different
Clark Kent than the one in the comics
even come on Clark I think we better get
out of here I think we better do what he
says come on come on get in here quick
don't don't do anything it's all right
bumbling unsure of himself somebody that
that uh Lois Lane played by Margo Kidder
would never be like this could be
Superman not Clark Clark's an idiot
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's no mistake or accident that
I grew up and married a journalist
because I grew up watching Margot Kidder
play Lois Lane you know she was real she
was her own person she was in charge she
could dismiss Clark Kent you know she
was a master at her job not great at
spelling but doesn't matter man we got
spell check nowadays the Kirk Allen
Superman always forgotten unheralded
never gets his due first got to put on
the tights first got to wear the S and
the cape and make it work you know up
until then only children had put on a
cape and ran around a yard this is the
first grown ass man who's like I'll do
it I mean yeah but I better get paid but
like I'll do it you know he carried
himself insanely well looks like
Superman has a spit curl the only
problem is it was made at a time 1948
where you know your effects are very
very limited and Superman is all about
what he can do his abilities you know
leap tall buildings in a single bound
that sort of thing so they couldn't pull
that off as well but for the time you
know you had an audience that wasn't
looking for sophisticated special
effects like we have today Henry Cavill
as Superman probably honestly the
prettiest Superman we've had so easy to
look at and I was a big fan of Henry's
stuff in the Tudors he was Henry's best
friend his moral conscience so I think
Henry's a wonderful actor I think he did
great in the role absolutely wonderful
you know his Superman really his Clark
Kent was very decidedly different than
the earlier iterations of Clark Kent you
know I I love what Zack Snyder did with
Man of Steel and bvs Batman be Superman
for those not in the know is Superman of
course also very controversially snapped
General zod's neck
[Music]
which I didn't quite understand why it
was controversial considering in
Superman too General Zod has also killed
in the Fortress of Solitude they just
presumably leave his body there
so when people were like hey man this
ain't Superman I'm like I don't know
Superman was killing people in the in
the 70s and the 80s as well
[Music]
Batman has been a best friend of mine
since I was a child you know since I was
three four years old Batman has been a
big feature
in my life so when you say Batman who's
the first Batman actor that pops into my
head it's Kevin Conroy Merry Christmas
Joker Kevin Conroy has been the voice of
Batman for what three decades at this
point and his portrayal of the character
is absolutely Pitch Perfect his Bruce
Wayne is Pitch Perfect and his Batman is
Pitch Perfect it carries the sadness of
a childhood robbed and it's kind of
marshaled by the Assurance of somebody
who knows they are doing the exact right
thing in life it's horrible to lose
anybody in this life but to be there at
the scene of a crime and be ineffective
to have no power to make a difference
that's what fuels that character so
Kevin Conroy captures that perfectly he
never forgets that at the center of
Batman is a sad broken little boy who
lost everything so right after Kevin
Conroy of course I was was raised by
Adam West Batman that was my first
Batman my childhood love the bright
night as Adam West used to call himself
but Tim Burton's Batman Michael Keaton
will forever be my Batman you have to
understand I know nowadays everyone gets
a comic book movie every 10 seconds and
stuff but like on June 23 1989 like I
remember it like it's my kid's birthday
we got a version of Batman that was so
close to what we knew from the comics
when this movie came out and they cast
Michael Keaton like when they made that
announcement there was no internet at
this time and it still broke the [ __ ]
internet because people were like Mr Mom
is Batman what are you nuts and then one
day Warner Brothers put out the first
photo of Michael Keaton wearing the bat
costume standing next to the Batmobile
and the whole world shut up this is a
guy doing this
30 40 years before anyone started
treating this [ __ ] seriously like
nowadays you make movies where like
Christian Bale who also played Batman
wonderfully comes over to play Gore the
butcher in a Thor movie and stuff like
that in Batman Tim Burton's Batman in
1989 Bruce Wayne Michael Keaton's
version of Bruce Wayne is always
distracted look at the first 20 minutes
of that movie he's always like huh oh
yes huh oh certainly yeah
okay
because Bruce Wayne means nothing to him
Wayne Manor means nothing to him Beyond
his connection to his parents he is
truly Batman and as he's walking around
as Bruce Wayne he doesn't quite know how
to function properly the only way he can
feel himself is in the suit avenging
evil so there's a moment in Batman
Returns Batman is in uh was the bat ski
boat I think they call it Batman has a a
ride for everything he's going through
the sewers of Gotham headed toward the
penguins lair you know it's very heroic
music playing but two penguins pop out
of the water and they got missile
strapped to their back and Batman sees
it reacts and turns the wheel and the
skiff goes around the tunnel missing the
Penguins the ski boat writes itself past
the threat and they cut to this one shot
so quick blink and you'll miss it of
Batman in the bat ski boat the kind of
reaction shot to what just happened
and Michael Keaton encapsulates
everything I love about The Madness of
the world of Batman by doing simply this
that's it he just looks back as if like
I almost got killed by two [ __ ]
penguins with missiles on their backs
like what am I doing but he don't stop
it's not like I'm out of here he's just
like this is my life
now I'm just one man with one man's
opinion so I know the internet out there
right now half of them roasting me going
you forgot this you forgot that well
guess what here's your chance to let me
know what I forgot tell me what an
[ __ ] I am go to the comments and tell
me how I [ __ ] up that's what my mom
does she goes to the comments of every
article I'm in tells me how I [ __ ] up
you get to do the same right now to the
fine folks at GQ thanks for having me
those were my fine points foreign